finally yes after 410 adays select a big
rock was on your chest and suddenly you
moved so it was such a feeling it's hard
to describe that moment I was like
jumping and jumping you can see it in
feel it but to describe those moments
with words i think it's i can but it's
it's finally at home the children was
different it was like it was something
different as soon as he saw me he saw me
on the stairs they suddenly jump jumped
on me so I took them I start hugging
them I like you start saying I think I
start crying and this is the first time
when my children start telling me stop
going to work don't leave again he spent
too much time and worked so don't go
again we want you to stay
we should stay strong for those who are
supporting us we should understand this
is not for bad Peter and family no it's
for a bigger cause so that kept a strong
through the whole period and we are
planning to I don't know how but we
should return the favor for every single
person who did that December 29th 2013
al Jazeera